Claude Code is the most powerful agent
coding agent in the world. But did you
know that we can make it 100% private,
100% local, and 100% free? And the best
part is that it's actually really easy
to do. We just take the Agentic harness
that sits on top of Sonnet and Opus 4.6
and put it on top of a local open-source
model that lives on our computer. This
allows us to maintain the cloud code
infrastructure. Yet all of our
conversations and all of our code and
all our back and forths no longer leave
our computer at all. It is completely
private and again it's completely free.
And in this video I'm going to show you
exactly how that's done and we'll have a
discussion about the real tradeoffs
going the local route. So all the
commands for everything we do today can
be found here inside of my free school
community. There's a link to that in the
description. So if you ever get lost,
you're like, "Hey, what was that command
again?" And you can just come inside of
here, copy it, and paste it in. And
also, while we're here, just a quick
plug for my Claude Code Master Class. I
just updated 20 of the modules inside of
here, added an additional hour of
content, and this is the number one
place for going from zero to AI dev,
even if you don't come from a technical
background. The master class can be
found inside of Chase AI Plus. There's a
link to that in the pin comment. Now,
before we go into the how in terms of
the local cloud code setup, let's have a
quick discussion about the why, the pros
and cons, and the trade-offs because
there are some significant trade-offs
that we need to be aware of when we opt
to do a local claude code setup. Now,
the first and most obvious trade-off is
the models, right? On my normal cloud
code, I have Opus 4.6, Sonnet 4.6,
bestin-class, and their benchmarks
reflect that. Right? This is the SWE
verified test. This is just a very
common benchmark seeing how well these
models do on particular coding tasks and
Sonnet and Opus are basically at 80%.
Now below that we have the free local
models that are available to us to run
again free of charge if our computer is
powerful enough to use them. Keyword
being if now the most powerful right now
is GLM 4.7 which runs at 73.8 on this
test which is 91% of Opus, right? That's
amazing. However, do you have 48 GB of
RAM? Do you have a machine that could
actually run this? Chances are no. And
that probably applies to Quen 3 coder
next as well. So, for most people, even
though we have some open- source local
models that can sort of compete with the
big boys, at least on paper, this is
outside our reach. So, where does that
leave us? Well, that leaves us with
models like these three. GLM 4.7 Flash,
Quen 2.5, some of these smaller
parameter models. Now, are they as
effective? Obviously not right. 59.2%
versus 80 is a 20% drop off. But we can
run GLM 4.7 Flash on like a modern
MacBook Pro for sure. Right now 59.2
just seems like a random number in
space. What the heck does that actually
mean? Well, that is the equivalent of
like 3.7 Sonnet. Right? If you remember
Claw 3.7 Sonnet came out about a year
ago. I believe it was February 2025. So
you can kind of look at it this way. The
local free models are basically as good
as the front tier models from a year ago
when it comes to most people's hardware,
right? That's not a terrible trade-off
because when 3.7 came out, we all kind
of loved it, right? And I'm telling you
now, you can run it for free on your
laptop locally. It's totally private.
Nobody ever sees your data. So, you
know, that's just kind of a rule of
thumb, right? It doesn't totally hold
for every single model, but just kind of
think of it that way because I know,
hey, 80% on benchmark, 59.2. What does
that even mean? It means we're a year
behind. And so we trade model efficiency
and model speed for privacy and a lower
cost. Right? For all intents and
purposes, this 59.2% is free, right? My
data will never go to anybody's servers,
it stays on my computer, and that's a
big deal if you're dealing with certain
types of data. And we also have to
remember, not only is it less effective,
these models are also just slower,
right? You're not running on the
hardware that they're running over in
Anthropic. You have whatever your
computer has. So tasks just take longer
and we'll talk later about what those
tasks should be. Where does it actually
make sense to employ these things? So
now let's talk about the install. I'm
going to assume you've already installed
Cloud Code at some time in the past. If
you haven't, the commands are very easy
to follow and they're inside of Chase AI
along with all the other commands. Once
you've downloaded Claude Code, we now
need to download O Lama. We are going to
use Olama to download these open-source
models. Remember, Claude Code is still
Claude Code even if we've swapped the
models with it. It's just a harness. And
so, this is how we're going to get our
new power source. Now, to install it is
very simple. The command is right here.
You're just going to head to ama.com,
copy that, paste it into your terminal,
and you'll be set. Now, once Olama's
installed, we can have it pull any model
we want onto our computer. Now, if I go
up to models here in the top left, I
have the full gambit of open source
models, and there is a lot of open-
source models. So the obvious question
becomes which one should I choose? Now
there's really three ways to figure out
what local model makes sense for you.
The first way is very simple. Just spin
up your normal instance of cloud code
and tell it hey I'm trying to download
an open source model. Which one should I
use? It will go through it can look at
your hardware for you. Also go on on the
web see what is the best local model for
your particular setup at that time and
tell you which one to download. That's
super easy. You don't have to think.
Another way we can figure this out is by
using the LLM fit tool. This is an open-
source repo on GitHub. I will put a link
to this in the description, but if you
install this tool, it will take a look
at your system and figure out, hey,
which model makes sense. The third way
is to just go to your favorite AI
chatbot and tell it what you're trying
to do. Hey, I'm trying to download an
open source model from Olama. I have no
idea which one I should do. Also, I
don't even have any idea how much RAM my
computer has. How do I find this out?
Well, any AI chatbot will walk you
through this as well. I suggest these
three ways because the best model for
you today might be a different model
tomorrow. And doing it one of these
three ways will make sure you always
have the best one at that time. Now,
once I've figured out which model makes
sense for me, I'm just going to go
inside of search models and look for it.
So, if I'm doing GLM flash, I see, hey,
GLM 4.7 flash. It's been pulled 682,000
times. This one's probably it. Now, all
these models have different versions and
they tend to be different sizes. The
larger the size, the the more powerful
they tend to be. So, also when you're
asking AI which one should I choose,
have it tell you the exact size. In this
case, I'm just going to be using Flash
4.7 latest. Now, to actually download
the model is very simple, but it's not
this command right here. This command
will actually run the model inside of
your terminal, but we need to download
it. We need to pull it. So, what we're
going to do is we're going to run pull
and then whatever the model name is. And
so to do that, you're just going to open
your terminal, type lama pole, and then
whatever model that is. So for me,
GLM4.7 flash. I'm just going to hit
enter, and it's going to download the
entire thing. And once you download it,
you have that AI model just sitting on
your computer. You can actually work
with it directly. That's what this
command over here is, the lama run gm
4.7 flash, right? I could just talk to
it like that. But what we want to do is
we now want to take that model and we
want to put the cloud code harness on
top of it and get every and get
everything cloud code gives us just with
this free local model. Now the easiest
way to do this is with an alias because
chances are I don't want to only be able
to log into my local claude code. I want
to be able to use normal claude code as
well. Maybe I want to use both of them
at the same time. So normally, right,
when I'm inside of my terminal and I
want to use claude, I just do claude.
But we're going to set it up. So instead
of just saying, you know, claude, if you
do claude-lo,
it will then spin up the local version
for you. That simple. But to do that,
you're going to need an alias. And the
alias setup is different whether you're
on a Mac, a Linux, a Windows using Git,
or if you're doing PowerShell. Again,
all the commands are inside here, and I
walk you through exactly how to do it.
So what you're going to do is you're
going to come to this page, and you're
simply going to copy the correct one for
you, go inside your terminal, and paste
it in there. So since I'm on PowerShell,
I would just copy this whole thing. Now
what is this actually saying? Well, it's
saying the anthropic authentication
token is now set to O Lama, which is
your local computer. There's no longer
an enthropic API key associated with it
cuz again, we're not going to anthropic
servers. And the anthropic base URL is
again being sent to localhost 11434,
which is where Olama lives. So once
you've set up the alias according to the
instructions, now you can just log into
your local cloud code network just like
you would normal cloud code except this
time we just do claude-lo. And so you
can see here that it's now using GLM4.7
flash. It says API usage billing and
that's just a quirk of cloud code. It's
not actually billing anything cuz it's
just on your computer. And again, it's
reflected down here in my status bar. So
right now I am using cloud code for free
and everything is on my main computer
right nothing's even connected to the
internet and at this point you're done
you have a local setup you can call it
whenever you want just by using this
command and you can run claude code
normally right now you have two options
now the obvious question when should I
be using this right you probably have a
pretty good idea after our talk earlier
like all right I understand the
trade-offs it's not as effective it's
slower but it's free and it's local so
like what are the true use cases well I
think there's really three use cases for
your local model. Now, the first one's
pretty obvious, and that's if you're
running into token or usage limits with
normal cloud code. Not everybody can
afford to pay the $100 max plan or the
$200 max plan. So, having a local backup
model while you're waiting for your
usage to reset is genuinely useful. The
second use case is really anything that
is like simple or straightforward tasks.
Think of things like writing or even
like basic content or research type
things. Things that don't require a
crazy amount of context. don't require a
ton of tool calls. Tool calls being
important and really anything that isn't
like coding. You know, if you pay
attention to clawed code like on Opus
4.6 when it's running it stuff, it will
often times use 30 40 50 tool calls.
You're not going to get that same
effectiveness with these local models.
So, the simpler the tasks, the more it
makes sense to use something like GLM
4.7 flash. And frankly, for a lot of
people, they might kind of scoff at that
and like, well, I don't do anything
simple. Most people's projects are much
simpler than you think. Again, rewind a
year. What were you doing with Sonnet
3.7? That's kind of what you have here.
And the third use case, which isn't
totally spelled out here, is
projects that require data privacy,
right? Obviously, there's like
enterprise situations and there's deals
you can go into with places like OpenAI
or even Anthropic when it comes to like
data privacy. But if you're doing
something for a client and it's small
and it's like we're not operating on
that level, but I still just can't have
this exposed to wherever. Being able to
handle their data and work on it with an
agentic coding agent in a local
environment is a huge value ad, right?
So if you're someone who is dealing with
sensitive data, this is a way you can do
it without just like throwing your hands
up in the air and being like, well, I
just can't use a coding agents for it.
Now, the last thing I want to mention
are these cheap cloud options. So, Olama
does have the ability or gives us the
ability to use its local models in the
Olama cloud, which are a bit more
powerful. Remember how I was talking
about some of these local models that
are like 90% of Opus' power, yet you
can't run them on your computer? Well,
Olama will let you do that for a price
on the API. So, understand that is an
option as well. I'm not going to dive
super deep into that space. Just
understand if you do that, your data
isn't totally private anymore. So that's
kind of like the in between between
fully local and fully hooked up to
Anthropic and Olama gives you the full
breakdown of what to do here to set that
up. It's pretty simple. And the last
thing I want to show you is the speed
difference because this is something
most people don't realize at first. Like
it is significant. So I'm going to say
hi right to both of these at the same
time. Normal Claude code on the left,
local cloud code on the right. And we'll
see how long it takes for each one to
respond.
And mind you, I'm on a 5090 graphics
card.
So significant significant difference in
speed. So that is another thing you need
to factor in. But again, what is your
use case? Can you deal with the
slowness? So to sum it up, you should
now understand what the pros and cons
are doing a local cloud code setup. You
should understand how it works. And
really, you should also understand that
this isn't a, you know, blanket solution
for anything. You're going to use the
normal cloud code more often than not.
Yet, it's important to just have this in
your back pocket because there are some
niche use cases where it makes sense to
have a local setup. And I also think
it's important to kind of learn about
these open- source and local tools
because they're only getting more and
more powerful. So, it's not crazy to
think even a few years down the line
that they are competing with the big
boys at a much closer level. So, let me
know in the comments what you thought.
Make sure to check out Chase AI Plus if
you want to get your hands on the master
class.